[Musik]
das ist das thema das uns am meisten
beschäftigt deutschland in der krise
deutschland kämpft um jeden cent um
wärme um ein gutes leben die preise sie
schießen ins unermessliche und ein ende
ist bislang nicht in sicht viele
menschen viele familien wissen nicht
mehr weiter und haben keine ahnung wie
sie ihr leben noch finanzieren sollen
kanzler so geht's nicht weiter so
titelbild heute angesichts der krise die
wir alle in unseren portemonnaie spüren
die preise für lebensmittel explodieren
die für sprit sowieso und die inflation
die ist seit monaten auf rekordniveau
und deshalb kämpft bild für sie damit
unser leben ein bisschen so bleibt wie
es früher war für ein bisschen
sicherheit in zeiten in denen fast
nichts sicher scheint ja erstmals seit
jahrzehnten müssen wir uns tatsächlich
vor dem winter fürchten erste gemeinden
planen jetzt sogar schon wärmer hallen
einzurichten konzert stadien sollen
umgerüstet werden damit sich menschen
aufwärmen können wenn es zu hause kalt
bleibt und in der letzten woche hatte
sogar die erste
wohnungsbaugenossenschaft in sachsen
ihren mietern die warmwasserversorgung
reduziert duschen waschen also nur noch
zu bestimmten zeiten und in nordrhein
westfalen da gibt es erste landkreise in
denen jetzt schon nicht mehr geheizt
wird da sind sind zwar gerade
sommerferien aber die maßnahme gilt
vorerst bis ende september also kein
warmwasser zum beispiel nach dem
schulsport kann frage also deutschland
steckt mitten in der krise wie können
wir sparen wie kommen wir gemeinsam
durch diese krise wir haben ihnen
versprochen bild kämpft für sie und bei
uns ist jetzt frank ochse ganz genau
diese fragen beantworten wird
[Musik]
frank du hast uns spartipps mitgebracht
und wir starten mit dem ersten da geht
es um das thema duschen genau der
bundeswirtschaftsminister sagt zwei
minuten reichen bei ihm muss aber gar
nicht sein also zwei minuten ist
wirklich sehr sehr kurz aber tatsächlich
kann man da eine ganze menge tun wenn
man sich mal überlegt ich dusche am tag
vielleicht acht minuten und dann bei
relativ angenehm 42 grad das kann man
wirklich leicht reduzieren und spart
dadurch also zum beispiel mein vorschlag
wäre tatsächlich 38 grad und nur fünf
minuten und glaubt es kaum was man da so
spart nämlich im jahr
367 euro war hus kopf noch dazu der
kostet so um die 25 euro und dann 367
euro im jahr ist schon mal ein knaller
[Musik]
gucken wir aufs tanken das ist ja auch
gerade eine sache da treibt den meisten
deutschen tränen in den augen bei den
preisen wie kann man da ein bisschen
tricksen bisschen sparen ganz wichtig
bloß nicht wenn ich zur arbeit fahre
gleich noch schneller an die tankstelle
sondern abends zwischen 18 und 22 uhr da
sparen sie bis zu sieben cent pro liter
das ist ganz ordentlich
[Musik]
licht ist auch ein großes thema in der
energiekrise alte glühbirnen ersetzen
durch neue led es nützt das was absolut
man denkt immer so naja die lampen
brennen ja noch die alten glühlampen und
60 watt so aber ich rate dazu wirklich
austauschen auch da ist das
sparpotenzial wirklich in ordnung wir
mal 10 60 watt glühlampen die noch
funktionieren diverse jetzt einfach mal
raus und ersetzt die durch led-leuchten
da spare ich tatsächlich
165 euro pro jahr also auch wirklich
richtig viele also jetzt schnell
austauschen die eulen lampen raus und
kräftig sparen und die halten auf jeden
fall deutlich länger
ja auch in der küche beim kochen kann
man ordentlich geld einsparen frank ich
mache das auch immer gern ein bisschen
warten und dann für seinen bereits ein
bisschen vorheizen und somit warum
dauert das so lange mache ich jetzt auch
nicht mehr ich versuche es bei der pizza
bisschen schwer aber tatsächlich herd
stadt offen tatsächlich also wer da den
ofen doch weniger bewusst spart auch
eine ganze menge nämlich wirklich ein
viertel energie und ganz wichtig wenn
man den herd benutzt wenn man kocht mit
töpfen was nicht immer ein deckel drauf
und das spart noch mal 50 prozent oder
einfach gar nicht kochen
so ein system an
[Musik]
da schauen wir uns den kühlschrank mal
genauer an dann auch der hat
einsparpotenzial ja ich habe meinen
kühlschrank immer sehr sehr kühl
gehalten sind schönes kaltes bier eine
schöne limo eiskalt ist natürlich ein
knaller aber ich habe gelernt wenn das
obere fach wirklich sieben grad hat und
nicht vielleicht zwei grad spare ich da
auch eine ganze menge also zum beispiel
sechs grad würde ich sparen wenn ich von
6 grad auf 7° erhöhe sozusagen reicht
für frische waren total aus je kälter
desto teurer also auf jeden fall sieben
grad oberstes fach ist ein knaller die
kleine schritte machen dann also am ende
des jahres und großen unterschied aus
vielen dank an unseren sparfuchs frank
ochse